i hope to do a podcast one day with my
son i think this is nice this is how old
you have two kids right i have a
nine-year-old boy and a nine-month-old
boy so yeah it's going to be a few years
before i get no you could do one with a
nine-year-old and i guarantee it'll be a
lot of fun i bet you should do one with
a nine-year-old to do one with a
nine-year-old would be a i think that's
a i i think he'd be right he's a funny
kid my nine-year-old he's a funny kid i
bet you he is yeah he's fine i also
does he love touring with you
um he does i'm giving him a job
backstage in this australian like a
mother-in-law yeah
i'm getting a job just to be like a
dog's body and run around and do things
for my manager and stuff so that he gets
a bit of a work ethic into him i did
that with him we had a bartender i don't
know if that's illegal or not but soon
we're only going to have a couple of
spirits and a few beers just get that
person a beer pour them with vodka and
whatever oh yeah roll that one a doobie
yeah
illegal in australia like is it real
that was one of the things i didn't
quarantine because i'm sober but i um i
still partake uh with with uh weed right
so i i i
without that i find it very hard not to
drink and i um so when i was in
quarantine i asked somebody a friend of
mine to bake me some some weed brownies
big tray of those and uh because you get
food delivered and lots of stuff but
these were all in a tupperware container
i mean they were delivered to me by a
cop and i thought oh [ __ ] i'm in trouble
here and he just was like these of you
mr jeffries and hand them over the dog
didn't check him or anything so
he didn't know that they had you had a
cop deliver a box of weed to my room in
australia while i was quoting why is it
illegal there it seems like that's a
very progressive uh country
when it comes to drugs they're not very
progressive uh we have legalized
prostitution so we're we're ahead of the
game on that you know which is
societally that
is the best thing you can go they have
to pay taxes they get std checks there's
there's uh brothels the girls are safer
all that type of stuff they've proven
that that's and the divorce rates drop
substantially you know there's there's
no downside to it cookers are great yeah
fantastic and they're just on high
streets there isn't a stigma around it
just one second i'm talking to jeremy
who's our producer here the title for
this um
episode is going to be hookers and [ __ ]
hookers in conspiracy with jim jeffries
yeah they go
together um but we they're still very
you know like like let's let's mention
another drug so cocaine in australia
cost anywhere between
uh 300 and 400 dollars a gram which why
do you know that because there's no
things i just i'm a knowledgeable man
and over here it's like 50 bucks for a
gram of cocaine right so it's like
there are some drawbacks to being a
large island
you know so
[Laughter]
all of our cocaine's brought in and
condoms up people's asses you know what
i mean so it's a limited supply uh but
so australia has a lot of like
um
people
synthetic drugs speed and stuff like
that people that bikers can make in labs
and stuff like that i don't know how i
got into this i'm just saying that
they're not there's no drugs that are
legal there's nothing i remember we i
was asking about your kid touring with
you
yeah so i'm gonna make him just get the
boot and the spoon and the lighter
[Music]